.
* Ruhige Celloklänge *
Die Vormundschaftsbehörde
hat mir gesagt,
ich würde
in ein schönes Mädchenheim kommen,
mit gleichaltrigen Mädchen.
Ich könne mit ihnen zusammen aus-
wärts in einer Spinnerei arbeiten.
Ich würde
mein eigenes Geld verdienen.
Ich dachte,
als Heimkind hast du keine Rechte,
dann machst du das halt.
Ich wurde 18 Jahre alt.
Da hatte ich das Bedürfnis,
wieder einmal meine Mutter zu sehen.
Ich habe sie sehr selten gesehen.
Nichts ahnend.
Ich freute mich und dachte,
meine Mutter holt mich ab.
Und wer steht am Bahnhof?
Frau Seifert vom Fürsorgeamt.
Ich habe die Welt
nicht mehr verstanden.
Dann hat sie gesagt:
"Elfriede,
du gehst nicht mehr zurück."
"Du kommst jetzt
mit dem Zug nach Dietfurt."
Die Vormundschaftsfrau.
Sie hat während der ganzen Reise
keinen Ton mit mir gesprochen.
Nichts.
* Ruhige Celloklänge *
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Als die jungen Frauen
in Dietfurt im Toggenburg ankamen,
hatten sie keine Ahnung,
was sie erwartet.
In der Spinnerei sollten sie
für den damals reichsten Mann
der Schweiz arbeiten:
für Emil Bührle.
Waffenfabrikant,
Kriegsprofiteur und Kunstsammler.
Als wir in Dietfurt ankamen,
empfing uns eine Schwester Oberin.
Da dachte ich: "Wow, aber nicht
schon wieder Klosterfrauen."
Sie macht die Türe auf.
Ich sehe einen Sechserschlag,
sechs Betten,
sechs schmale Schränke.
Ich packte meine sieben Sachen aus.
Ich besass ja nicht viel.
Die Schwester Oberin
hat mir den Speisesaal gezeigt.
Als ich diesen riesigen Speisesaal
gesehen habe,
wo mind. 100 Personen
drin Platz hatten,
dachte ich: "Oh Irma, jetzt bist du
wieder in einem Heim gelandet."
Das Marienheim.
Es wurde von Ingenbohler Schwestern
geleitet und gehörte Emil Bührle.
Heute ist es ein Wohnhaus.
Von der ehemaligen Spinnerei
ist es nur wenige Meter entfernt.
Vor 65 Jahren stand Irma Frei
zum ersten Mal vor dieser Tür.
Grüezi.
- Herr Rutz, grüezi.
Willkommen in unserem Haus.
- Danke.
Ich hoffe,
sie haben auch positive Gedanken.
Mal schauen.
Fritz Rutz, der Hausbesitzer,
führt Irma Frei durchs Haus.
Am Abend,
als wir hier reinkamen,
mussten wir hier
die Schuhe wechseln.
Ja, ja.
- Da hängten wir die Wäsche auf.
Ja, das ist jetzt noch so.
Wie vor 60 Jahren,
wie vor 60 Jahren.
Mein Gott,
es hat sich nichts verändert.
Es ist immer noch so.
- Ja.
Es stimmt so genau.
Es ist, als ob du in ein Loch
hineinläufst, es kommt alles wieder.
Sie waren insgesamt
etwa drei Jahre hier?
Ja, korrekt, drei Jahre.
Ich habe mir vorgestellt,
das sei eine grosse Pension
und es seien etwa 10, 15 Mädchen.
Die Schwester Oberin sagte dann:
"Irma, geh in den Aufenthaltsraum
zu diesen drei Mädchen."
Sie haben mir dann gesagt:
"Du musst morgens
um 4 Uhr aufstehen."
"Dann gehen wir zusammen
in die Spinnerei zur Schichtarbeit."
Ich habe gefragt:
"Wie lange bleibt ihr denn hier?"
Sie haben mir dann gesagt:
"Irma, mach dir keine Hoffnungen."
"Hier kommst du nicht mehr raus,
bis du 20 bist."
Das war gerade nochmals heavy.
Das habe ich nicht erwartet.
Wer ins Marienheim kam, hatte meist
schon Schlimmes hinter sich.
Irma Frei wuchs in Schaffhausen auf.
Die Familie war bitterarm.
Der Vater alkoholkrank,
manchmal gewalttätig.
Als ich sieben war,
liessen sich meine Eltern scheiden.
Dann kam die Amtsvormundschaft
Schaffhausen
und hat uns Kinder alle getrennt.
Dann hat man mich weiter abgeschoben
ins Kinderdorf Rathausen.
Das war eine sehr schlimme Zeit.
Im Kinderheim waren über 200 Kinder.
Es wurde
von Ingenbohler Schwestern geführt.
Dort war das Motto
"Zucht und Ordnung".
* Düstere Klavierklänge *
Meine Mutter
hat mir mit 80 Jahren gesagt:
"Ich hätte dich eigentlich
abtreiben müssen."
Sie hat mir das anvertraut.
Meine Mutter wurde mit mir,
dem vierten Kind, schwanger.
Da hat man im Fürsorgeamt gesagt:
"Das kommt nicht mehr infrage."
"Das gibt es nicht."
"Das müssen Sie abtreiben,
fertig Schluss."
"Und sonst gibt es
ganz schlimme Repressalien."
"Für Sie und für das Kind."
Man hat ihr gedroht.
Dann hat sie mich
oben in der Frauenklinik geboren.
Und am gleichen Tag kam ich
weg von der Mutter ins Heim.
Was das für ein Verlust war,
für beide,
das ist mir heute noch bewusst.
Von da an war ich immer
in Heimen, immer in Heimen.
Es macht mich traurig,
wenn ich darüber sprechen muss.
Eine Kopie der Fürsorgeakten
aus dem Staatsarchiv Schwyz.
Unter keinen Umständen
will Carmen Scheiwiller,
dass jemand diese Akten liest.
Sie war ein Jahr alt,
als sie die Fürsorge
ins Kinderheim Einsiedeln steckte.
Es hat schon
mit dem Essen angefangen.
Am Mittwoch, z.B.,
hatten wir am Nachmittag schulfrei.
Wir mussten in den Luftschutzkeller.
Dort hatte es
zwei grosse, lange Tische,
mit Bergen von Kartoffeln.
Die Buben mussten
an einem Tisch Kartoffeln spitzen
und die Mädchen an einem anderen.
Und wir mussten bis zum Schluss
Rosenkränze beten,
sodass wir ja nicht
miteinander schwatzten.
Diese Kartoffeln
mussten wir in grosse Fässer legen,
in die man Wasser schüttete.
Am Mittwoch.
Diese Kartoffeln mussten dann
bis zum nächsten Mittwoch reichen.
Aber das Wasser wurde nie geleert.
Am Schluss mussten wir
schwarze Kartoffeln essen.
Das war so ekelhaft, das können
Sie sich gar nicht vorstellen.
Und gestunken hat es!
Wie eine Sautränke.
Alle Heimstationen von Carmen Schei-
willer sind in ihren Akten vermerkt.
Bis zur Volljährigkeit,
damals mit 20.
Aber das, was sie wirklich
erleiden musste, steht nicht drin.
Bei allem haben sie
etwas Schlechtes gedacht.
Wir waren im Bett,
24 Mädchen im gleichen Zimmer.
Die Schwester
lief im Gang hin und her,
mit dem Gebetsbüchlein, betete.
Auf einmal kam sie ins Zimmer,
betete weiter
und irgendwo legte sie
das Büchlein hin
und zog bei irgendjemandem
die Decke weg.
Und wenn es kalt ist im Zimmer,
dann zieht man als Kind
die Knie hoch und legt
die Hände zwischen die Knie.
Wenn sie das sah,
wurdest du verprügelt.
Aber richtig verprügelt.
Danach musstest du ins Badezimmer.
Dort hatte es drei Badewannen.
Eine war immer mit Wasser gefüllt.
Dann musstest du dich
in die Badewanne setzen.
Dann hat sie dich runtergedrückt.
Ich musste auch mal gehen.
Da habe ich gesagt: "Schwester,
darf ich selbst untertauchen?"
"Ich gehe ganz sicher runter."
Da hat sie gesagt:
"Ich mache schon so, wie ich will."
Dann hat sie dich am Hals gepackt
und nach hinten runtergedrückt.
Bis es gurgelte.
Dann konntest du wieder hochkommen.
Ob Sommer oder Winter -
danach musstest du wieder
ins kalte Zimmer.
Du hättest niemandem
etwas sagen dürfen.
Die Leute
hätten dir nicht geglaubt.
Dann wäre es
auf dich zurückgefallen.
Es war schon schlimm.
Irma Frei war 17, als sie
ins Marienheim geschickt wurde.
Um 4.55 Uhr wurde eingestempelt.
Punkt 5 Uhr stellte der
Maschinenmeister die Maschinen an.
* Beunruhigende Violinenklänge *
Diese Pfosten
sind alle noch original.
Sie waren früher braun.
Da waren mind. eins, zwei, drei,
vier, fünf, sechs, sieben ...
Etwa acht Maschinen standen dort,
alle gleich.
Man machte eine Maschine
nach der anderen
und hatte ständig zu tun.
Da hast du die leere Spule,
da nimmst du den Flügel ab,
legst ihn hin, nimmst die volle
Spule raus, die leere wieder rein.
Du musstest immer schauen,
dass sie laufen, laufen, laufen.
Du konntest auch
keine Pausen einschalten.
Es war trostlos.
Trostlos. Schwerstarbeit.
Morgens um 5 Uhr
musstest du antraben.
Es war lärmig und stinkig
und du musstest liefern, liefern.
Und wenn du nicht
einen starken Eigenwillen hast,
gehst du unter.
Und den Gefallen
habe ich ihnen nicht gemacht.
Den habe ich ihnen nicht gemacht.
So.
Elfie Grendene war verheiratet,
ist Mutter von drei Kindern
und hat zwei Enkelkinder.
Eine Familie, wie sie es sich
immer gewünscht hat.
Sie hat
ein Antiquitätengeschäft geführt
und war als Betagtenpflegerin tätig.
Eigentlich wollte ich es
mit Zwiebeln machen.
Aber das ginge zu lange.
Das hätte ich vorbereiten müssen.
Unabhängigkeit
war mein höchstes Ziel.
Mein ganzes Leben lang.
Das hat sich
wie ein roter Faden durchgezogen.
Auch heute. Ich weiss schon noch,
was ich will und was nicht.
Und jetzt kommt Trick 77.
Oh. Und dann ziehe ich daran.
Fast wie eine Bäckersfrau.
So.
Vor über zwei Jahren
hat Elfie Grendene
einen politischen Prozess
angestossen,
mit dem niemand gerechnet hatte.
Angefangen hat alles
mit dem Zürcher Kunsthaus.
Hier der Erweiterungsbau
mit der Sammlung Emil Bührle.
Ein Milliardenschatz -
und höchst umstritten.
Seit Jahren diskutieren Kunstsach-
verständige und Historikerinnen
über die Herkunft bestimmter Bilder.
Ebenso umstritten der Sammler,
Emil Bührle.
Der Deutsche, der 1937 die Schweizer
Staatsbürgerschaft erlangte,
machte aus
der Werkzeugmaschinenfabrik Oerlikon
ein florierendes Unternehmen und
produzierte im grossen Stil Waffen.
Der Rüstungsindustrielle lieferte
seine Waffen im Zweiten Weltkrieg
an Nazideutschland
und die Achsenmächte.
Das machte ihn
zum reichsten Mann der Schweiz.
Ich habe oft die Zeitungen gelesen.
Ich habe mich da immer vertieft.
Ich sah den Schlagabtausch
zwischen den Linken
und der "Zürcher Zeitung".
Dieses Hin und Her mit den
Waffen- und den Bildergeschichten.
Aber was da in der Schweiz abging,
das blieb immer schön
unter dem Deckel, jahrelang.
Da hat es langsam in mir gebrodelt.
Ich hatte das Gefühl: "Hallo,
nein, das geht einfach nicht."
Sie geht mit ihrer Geschichte
zur Zeitschrift "Beobachter".
Der "Beobachter" berichtet das erste
Mal über die Zwangsarbeiterinnen
im Marienheim und über
die Textilfabriken von Emil Bührle.
Das ist ...
- Nur ein bisschen, oder?
Alles Liebe und Gute.
Danke für die Begleitung.
Sehr gerne geschehen.
Auf den grossen Tag.
Elfie Grendene ist unterwegs
mit der ehemaligen Zürcher
SP-Gemeinderätin Christine Seidler.
Der Zürcher Gemeinderat diskutiert
einen Vorstoss von Seidler.
Der Vorstoss verlangt,
die Stadt Zürich solle die Rolle
der Fürsorgebehörden aufarbeiten
und einen Solidaritätsbeitrag zahlen.
Es berührt mich.
- Mich auch, wenn ich Sie so sehe.
Und ich finde, es ist auch Zeit.
Es ist höchste Zeit. Ja.
Ich bin wirklich dankbar,
dass ich hier sein darf,
für die vielen Opfer,
die irgendwo sind.
Als Stellvertretung.
- Als Stellvertretung.
Das braucht auch Mut.
- Ich war immer mutig.
Ja.
- Ja, ja.
Ich bin wirklich froh und dankbar,
dass die Zürcher Regierung
nach langem Zögern
und Auf-die-Seite-schieben,
sich ernsthaft
mit diesem Thema auseinandersetzt.
Es ist ein krasses Thema.
Da schaut man nicht gerne hin.
(Lautsprecher) Zürich Hauptbahnhof,
Ihre nächsten Verbindungen.
Du hattest immer
etwa fünf, sechs Maschinen.
Wir halfen einander. Wenn es
eine nicht schaffte, sagten wir:
"Komm, ich helfe dir schnell.
Dann ist es schneller gemacht."
Wenn du aber mal
mit anderen Mädchen geschwatzt hast,
dann ist es ab und zu vorgekommen,
dass z.B. ein Faden riss.
Dann hat es manchmal
eine ganze Reihe Fäden zerrissen.
Das war schlimm.
Dadurch hattest du
zu wenig Laufmeter auf der Maschine
und das hat manchmal
eine Abmahnung gegeben,
entweder ins Spinnereibüro
oder ins Büro im Marienheim.
Das wiederum
hatte mehr Arbeit zur Folge
oder der Spaziergang am Sonntag
wurde dir gestrichen.
Es war das Highlight der Woche:
4 Std. Ausgang am Sonntagnachmittag.
Es hat uns doch irgendwie gezeigt:
So ist es, wenn du mal rauskommst.
Du kannst gehen, wohin du willst.
Du kannst mal in ein Café sitzen.
So wie andere,
normale junge Leute auch.
Das bisschen Freiheit
darf nicht darüber hinwegtäuschen:
Die Frauen
waren nicht freiwillig in Dietfurt,
und dies ohne Gerichtsurteil.
Mind. 300 junge Zwangsarbeiterinnen
waren in den 1940er-, 1950er-
und 1960er-Jahren im Marienheim
und mussten für Emil Bührle,
später für seinen Sohn Dieter,
in den Textilfabriken arbeiten.
Dietfurt war aber kein Einzelfall.
In der ganzen Schweiz steckten Für-
sorgeämter junge Frauen in Fabriken.
Dabei war Zwangsarbeit seit 1941
in der Schweiz offiziell verboten.
Die jungen Frauen waren der
Fürsorgebehörde völlig ausgeliefert.
Auch als die
obligatorische Schulzeit endete
und die Mädchen
aus den Kinderheimen rauskamen -
die Fürsorge
bestimmte das Leben weiterhin.
Sie platzierte die Frauen bis zur
Volljährigkeit völlig willkürlich.
Bevor Irma Frei nach Dietfurt
ins Marienheim geschickt wurde,
arbeitete sie als Haushaltshilfe.
Ich kam dorthin
und merkte vom ersten Tag an,
dass mich diese Frau nicht mag.
Sie hatte immer,
immer etwas auszusetzen.
Ich kochte nicht richtig,
ich machte die Wäsche nicht richtig,
ich putzte nicht so,
wie sie es wollte.
In meinen Akten stand dann,
sie müssten mich
in diese Fabrik stecken,
weil ich
zu viele Pausen machen würde,
und ich müsste an "andauerndes
Arbeiten" gewöhnt werden.
Ich konnte gar nie Stellung nehmen
zu all diesen Vorwürfen,
weshalb ich ins Marienheim musste,
warum ich dort wegmusste,
warum die Frau reklamierte,
sie käme nicht mit mir zurecht.
Geschoben.
17, 27, 47.
50, 54, 64.
Mit 14 kam Carmen Scheiwiller
aus dem Kinderheim Einsiedeln raus.
Danach arbeitete sie ein Jahr lang
als Putzkraft in einem Spital.
Ich war so zufrieden dort.
Es bereitete mir grosse Freude,
wenn die Patienten
mit mir sprachen
und ich antworten durfte.
Das war für mich so schön.
Eines Tages
sagte eine Zimmerkollegin von mir,
es gäbe ein Theater,
ob ich auch mitkommen würde.
Dann habe ich gesagt:
"Ja, ich komme mit."
Da gab sie mir noch
einen Lippenstift,
um die Lippen zu schminken,
Jesses.
Zöpfe hatte ich,
einen Jupe und einen Pullover
und Schuhe mit Specksohlen.
Nun, auf jeden Fall
war das Theater zu Ende.
Dann fing der Tanz an.
Das vergesse ich nie.
Da kam ein Mann zu mir
und fragte mich etwas.
Ich wusste gar nicht,
was er wollte.
Ich sagte so blöd: "Was?"
Da sagte er: "Ist es erlaubt?"
Und ich sagte: "Was?"
Da sagte er: "Kommst du tanzen?"
Da sagte ich,
ich könne nicht tanzen.
Da sagte er:
"Komm, wir probieren es."
Das war schon falsch.
Danach hiess es auf einmal:
"Du musst deine Sachen packen,
du kommst an einen anderen Ort."
Sie war 15.
Ein Mädchen noch, als sie die
Fürsorge im Marienheim platzierte.
Sie arbeitete
in der Weberei in Bütschwil.
Auch diese Fabrik
gehörte Emil Bührle.
Es war ein abgekartetes Spiel.
Die brauchten noch Leute.
Das kam einem Mädchenhandel gleich.
Bührle brauchte Arbeiterinnen,
und die Fürsorgeämter ...
Ich denke, generell, gesamt-
schweizerisch haben sie sich bedient
und die Mädchen dorthin gebracht.
Und auch Kapital daraus geschlagen.
Ich muss es sagen.
Es tönt brutal, aber es war so.
Für die Fürsorge
die billigste Lösung.
Sie war ihre Mündel los
und hatte kaum mehr Kosten.
Die Massnahme hiess:
"Erziehung zur Arbeit".
Für Fabrikbesitzer wie Emil Bührle
ein äusserst profitables Geschäft.
Die Spinnerei in Dietfurt.
Im Dorf nebenan,
in Bütschwil, die Weberei.
Emil Bührle kaufte die Fabriken 1941
von deutsch-jüdischen Flüchtlingen
zu einem sehr niedrigen Preis.
Die beiden Textilfabriken
waren für das ganze Toggenburg
ein enormer Wirtschaftsfaktor.
In Spitzenzeiten arbeiteten Hunderte
von Arbeiterinnen und Arbeitern hier.
Zuunterst in der Hierarchie:
die Zwangsarbeiterinnen.
Wir erhielten nie Geld.
Das war Tabu,
darüber redete man nicht.
Wir waren auch eingeschüchtert.
Man sagte mir
in all diesen Jahren nie,
wie viel ich verdiene.
In all diesen Jahren
sah ich nie einen Lohnausweis
oder eine Monatsabrechnung.
Ich wusste nicht, was ich verdiente.
Ich musste auch nie
irgendetwas unterschreiben.
Ich hatte im Monat
5 Fr. Taschengeld, mehr nicht.
Die Löhne
flossen direkt ans Marienheim.
Mit dem Geld haben die
Ordensschwestern das Heim geführt.
Es reichte knapp, um Kost, Logis
und das Allernötigste zu decken.
So finanzierten die Frauen
ihre eigene Wegsperrung.
Das Kloster Ingenbohl in Brunnen,
Kanton Schwyz.
Im Klosterarchiv lagern die Chroniken
vom Marienheim in Dietfurt.
Die Ingenbohler Schwestern
sollten die jungen Frauen
nach den rigiden Moralvorstellungen
der katholischen Kirche
und der damaligen Gesellschaft
formen:
"Der Monat Januar
bringt uns acht Schweizerinnen."
"Sie kommen von der Vormundschaft."
Die Mission ist klar, nämlich
"unseren Mädchen den Weg
zu einem reinen Leben zeigen".
Dabei helfen sollen Filme
wie "Die Heilige von Lisieux".
Die Ordensschwestern
erwarten absoluten Gehorsam
und schreiben von Frauen,
die "glauben, mit Frechheiten
die Welt erobern zu können",
von Mädchen, die "herausfordernd"
sind und "sich öfters nicht fügen".
Regelmässig
versuchen junge Frauen zu fliehen.
Eine 17-Jährige probiert,
durch ein Fenster
in der Stube zu entkommen.
Ein Mädchen
nimmt in Bütschwil Reissaus.
Ein anderes flieht nach St. Gallen.
Ich habe auch mal
einer dazu verholfen.
Ich bin mit ihr spazieren gegangen.
Sie hat gefragt: "Kommst du
mit mir spazieren?" Ich sagte Ja.
Dann sagte sie:
"Weisst du, ich möchte ausreissen."
Und dann sagte ich:
"Ja, wenn du das willst."
Dann sagte sie:
"Ja, ich möchte gehen."
Dann sagte ich: "Hör mal, wir machen
es so, wenn du gehen willst."
"Ich gehe jetzt hier aufs WC."
"Dann gehst du einfach.
Ich habe es nicht gesehen."
Dann ging ich nach Hause.
Da haben sie gefragt:
"Wo ist deine Kollegin?"
Da habe ich gesagt, ich hätte
in Wattwil aufs WC gehen müssen
und als ich herauskam,
sei sie nicht mehr da gewesen.
Ich hatte nicht gelogen,
aber ich wollte sie
auch nicht verraten.
Der Ingenbohler Orden
will sich nicht äussern
und nimmt zum Marienheim
keine Stellung.
Die Schwestern teilen mit,
sie hätten sich bereits
mit ihrer Vergangenheit in den
Kinderheimen auseinandergesetzt
und sich vor zehn Jahren
öffentlich entschuldigt.
Da sieht man
auf den Speisesaal runter.
Nein, das war damals
der Aufenthaltsraum.
Der Aufenthaltsraum? Ich hörte,
es wäre der Speisesaal gewesen.
Nein, es war der Aufenthaltsraum.
Der Speisesaal
war direkt anschliessend.
Samstag und Sonntag
mussten wir im Aufenthaltsraum sein,
ausser es war
schönes Wetter am Sonntag,
dann hatten wir 4 Std. Ausgang.
Das war das Highlight der Woche.
Aber Ausgang nur gegen Kirchgang?
- Nur gegen Kirchgang. Das war so.
Sonntagmorgen, oh mein Gott.
Da mussten wir jeden Sonntagmorgen
in Zweierkolonnen
von Dietfurt nach Bütschwil gehen,
in die Kirche.
Diese drei Bänke waren immer für die
Mädchen im Marienheim reserviert.
Wir mussten immer 15 Min.,
bevor die Leute
in die Kirche kamen, da sein.
Religion bedeutete mir nichts.
Ich empfand es eher als Strafe,
als dass es mir gutgetan hätte.
Es tat manchmal schon weh,
wenn die Leute sagten:
"Habt ihr gesehen?
Das sind die gefallenen Mädchen."
Aber wir waren nicht
die "gefallenen Mädchen".
Nein, unser Pech war,
dass wir aus sozial
schwachen Verhältnissen kamen.
Das war es.
Und nicht, weil wir
"gefallene Mädchen" waren.
Und das wussten die Leute vom Dorf
eben leider nicht.
Die Schwestern
waren strikte dagegen,
dass wir mit der Bevölkerung
Kontakt aufnahmen.
Carmen Scheiwiller
ist zweimal verwitwet,
hat zwei Kinder,
fünf Stiefkinder und zwei Enkel.
Sie arbeitete u.a.
als Geschäftsführerin eines Cafés.
Da vorne ist der Ort,
an dem ich gearbeitet habe.
Hast du
in dem grossen Gebäude gearbeitet?
Gehen wir hier lang?
- Nein, hier lang.
Wirklich?
Sie lebt nicht weit
von der Weberei entfernt,
in der sie
als junges Mädchen gearbeitet hat.
Oft spaziert sie mit ihrer
Stieftochter am Fabrikareal vorbei.
Während über 20 Jahren
war die Textilindustrie
aus Bütschwil verschwunden.
Heute produziert hier
wieder eine Webmanufaktur
und stellt Küchen-
und Geschirrtücher her.
Lange hat Carmen Scheiwiller
nicht in der Weberei gearbeitet.
Es war Sonntag in Bütschwil,
als es hiess: "Du musst dann heute
nicht in die Kirche."
Da dachte ich:
"Was, nicht in die Kirche?"
Dann sagte sie: "Nein,
du musst deine Sachen packen."
Die anderen sagten: "Renn doch weg."
Es nahm ja ab und zu eine Reissaus.
Da sagte ich:
"Ja, wo soll ich hin?
Ich habe keinen Menschen."
"Ich habe niemanden auf der Welt."
Ich bin ganz allein
und ich hätte nicht gewusst,
wo ich hinmüsste.
Dann kam einfach ein Polizist,
wir fuhren mit dem Zug weg
und dann sagte er,
ob ich wüsste, wo ich hinkäme.
Ich sagte, ich wüsste nichts,
mir habe man nichts gesagt.
Aber ich vermutete schon etwas.
Man sagte früher eben,
der "Gute Hirte" und so, nicht wahr.
Da sagte ich, ich werde
in den Guten Hirten kommen.
Dann sagte er Ja.
Da dachte ich: "Verflucht noch mal."
Carmen Scheiwiller musste mit 16
ins geschlossene Erziehungsheim
zum Guten Hirten in Altstätten,
St. Gallen.
Warum, weiss sie bis heute nicht.
In der geschlossenen Anstalt blieb
sie bis zu ihrer Volljährigkeit.
Geht schon steil runter.
- Wirklich?
Ich will nicht, dass ich hinfalle.
Schön, mit dem Wind.
- Richtig schön.
Viele sind am Unrecht zerbrochen.
Wer überleben wollte,
brauchte einen grossen Willen
und eine Strategie.
Bei ihr ist es einfach so,
dass sie einen extremen Humor
entwickelt hat.
Ich glaube auch, um alles
ein bisschen zu überspielen.
Sie ist halt oft irgendwie so ...
Ja, ja.
Ich bin immer fröhlich. Ja.
Aber so konnte sie sich auch,
sagen wir mal,
über Wasser halten und
Kraft schöpfen, mit diesem Humor.
Mhm.
Hm?
Es wurde einfach immer
über dich hinwegbestimmt.
* Melancholische Klavierklänge *
Ich dachte einfach: "Verdammt,
warum war ich eingesperrt?"
"Ich habe ja nichts gemacht."
Plötzlich dachte ich:
"So viel wie andere
bin ich doch eigentlich auch wert."
Von da an ging es mir besser.
Ich habe an mir arbeiten müssen.
Sonst wäre ich,
glaube ich, heute noch ...
Ich weiss auch nicht wo.
Das geht nur
mit einem gesunden Selbstwertgefühl
und mit einer Würde,
die ich mir selber erarbeiten muss.
V.a. Eigenwert.
Den muss man sich erarbeiten.
Aber das muss man sich zuliebe tun.
Es ist nur die Liebe zu sich selber,
die das vermag.
Das Zürcher Gemeindeparlament
tagt in der Bullingerkirche.
Christine Seidler und Elfie Grendene
werden von Sozialvorsteher
Raphael Golta begrüsst.
Grüezi, Frau Grendene.
Grüezi. Es freut mich, dass Sie
den Weg hierher gefunden haben.
Hallo, Christine.
Haben Sie es gut gefunden?
- Ja, ich hatte tolle Begleitung.
Ja, das ist super.
Grüezi. Entschuldigung,
darf ich so Grüezi sagen?
Wer ist das?
- Ich bin der Gemeindepräsident.
Ah, okay.
Darf ich Ihnen das geben?
Das ist für Sie.
Und zwar habe ich
diese Karte gestern gefunden.
Morgenrot.
Darf ich sie öffnen?
- Tagesdämmerung. Morgenrot.
Ich dachte: "Wow, das ist es."
Jetzt bin ich gerade etwas nervös.
Vielen Dank.
Ich begrüsse zur 40. Sitzung
des Gemeinderates der Stadt Zürich.
Es geht um die Verordnung
"Solidaritätsbeitrag an Opfer
von fürsorgerischen Zwangsmassnahmen
und Fremdplatzierungen vor 1981".
Ich möchte vorausschicken, dass ich
von einer betroffenen Person
dieses Röslein
und eine Postkarte bekommen habe,
als Dankeschön,
dass wir das behandeln.
Das habe ich
gerne entgegengenommen.
Fremdplatzierungen
und Zwangsmassnahmen
zählen in ihrer Ungeheuerlichkeit
zu den dunkelsten Kapiteln
der Schweizer
und der Zürcher Sozialgeschichte.
Seitens der Behörden - und auch das
kann man den Akten entnehmen -
wurde mit unglaublicher Abschätzung
über diese Menschen geschrieben.
Die Stadt Zürich
stellt sich der Debatte.
Die Bührle-Erben hingegen
wollen sich nicht äussern.
Gratian Anda, hier links im Bild,
mit seiner verstorbenen Mutter
Hortense Anda-Bührle.
Die Zeitschrift "Bilanz"
schätzt das Vermögen
der Familie Anda-Bührle
auf 1 bis 1,5 Mrd. Fr.
Der 54-jährige Anda,
einer der Enkel von Emil Bührle,
nimmt keine Stellung zum Marienheim
und zu den Textilfabriken
seines Grossvaters.
Als der "Beobachter" die Geschichte
von Elfie Grendene publizierte,
meldete sich auch Irma Frei.
Die Geschichten der beiden Frauen
setzten
eine grosse Recherche in Gang.
Das Buch "Schweizer Zwangsarbeiter-
innen" von Yves Demuth erscheint.
Da hätte sich Irma Frei ein Zeichen
der Bührle-Erben gewünscht.
Keiner von diesen Bührle-Erben
hat sich je entschuldigt,
denn wir waren
ja nur billige Arbeitskräfte,
die ausgenützt worden sind.
Über 60 Jahre hat Irma Frei
ihre Geschichte verdrängt.
Dann liest sie
zum ersten Mal ihre Akten.
Es war schlimm.
Ich konnte mind. zwei Wochen lang
nicht schlafen.
Das war so schlimm,
was die in diesen Akten
alles geschrieben haben.
Als ob es
das Normalste der Welt wäre.
Aber alles verlogen.
Es war nichts so,
wie es geschrieben wurde.
Erst in den Akten sieht sie,
dass ihre Mutter
immer wieder versucht hat,
sie nach Hause zu holen.
"... komme nun nochmals
auf mein letztes Schreiben zurück
und wollte nun höflich anfragen,
wie es steht mit der Heimnahme
von dem Kind Irma."
"Sie haben ja nun das letzte Mal
Einsicht in unseren Haushalt gehabt,
sodass wir gerne
die Kleine auf Weihnachten
zu uns nach Hause holen möchten."
Wenn ich das früher gewusst hätte,
hätte ich bestimmt ein anderes
Verhältnis zu meiner Mutter gehabt.
Als ich entlassen wurde,
habe ich ganze 50 Fr. bekommen,
für die drei Jahre,
die ich gearbeitet habe.
Die Schwester Oberin hat gesagt,
das sei fürs Zugbillett
und ich solle Sorge tragen zum Geld.
Es müsse reichen,
bis ich in Freiheit
meinen ersten Lohn erhalten würde.
Wenn ich heute darüber nachdenke,
ist das ein Hohn, so etwas.
Ich habe mir eigentlich
immer vorgenommen:
"Du musst stark sein,
sonst überlebst du nicht."
Ich wollte all jenen,
die gesagt haben, du bist nichts,
du wirst nichts,
aus dir gibt es nichts,
beweisen, dass sie unrecht hatten.
Irma Frei hat als Model gearbeitet
und sich auf diese Weise
Abendkurse finanziert.
Sie lernte Schreibmaschine schreiben
und arbeitete in der Buchhaltung.
Mit 24 heiratete sie das erste Mal.
Gerne hätte sie eine Lehre
als Damenschneiderin gemacht.
Damals für ein Heimkind undenkbar.
Als ich rauskam, dachte ich:
"Lass alles hinter dir."
Es braucht kein Mensch zu wissen,
was ich für eine Jugend hatte.
Darum habe ich geschwiegen.
Ich erzählte es weder
meinem Mann noch meinen Kindern.
Und wenn meine Kinder fragten:
"Mami, was hast du in deiner Jugend
gemacht?", habe ich gesagt:
"Kinder,
ich hatte keine schöne Kindheit
und keine schöne Jugend."
"Ich möchte nicht darüber sprechen."
Sie haben erst vor zwei Jahren
erfahren, was Sache ist.
Ich habe draussen getischt.
- Ich möchte zuerst noch so einen.
Ist gut?
- Aha, so einer?
Musst du zuerst noch wach werden?
- Yes.
* Melancholische Klaviermusik *
Aus wenigen Sätzen
ist immer mehr geworden.
Es ist wie ein Stein
ins Rollen gekommen
und irgendwann sass ich hier
und versank total traurig
in mich hinein und dachte:
"Ui nein,
dass es das überhaupt gibt
und dass das
meinem Mami passiert ist,
dass mein Mami das hat
ertragen müssen, dieses Leid."
Und dann haben wir uns angeschaut
und dann hat meine Mutter
zum ersten Mal so richtig geweint
und hat mich in die Arme genommen.
Ich glaube, es ist,
als ob der ganze Schmerz und Frust
von ihr abgefallen wären.
Endlich konnte sie
darüber schreiben und reden,
wie sie es Jahrzehnte lang
nie gemacht hat.
Ich hatte dann,
auch wenn es etwas blöd klingt,
das erste Mal gesehen, wie meine
Mutter weint und Emotionen zeigt.
Irgendwie kam es mir
ein bisschen wie ein Puzzle vor,
von dem gewisse Teile fehlen,
und wir wissen nicht genau,
was das ist.
Es war wie eine schwarze Ecke,
und diese schwarze Ecke
ist jetzt gefüllt worden.
Das Puzzle ist jetzt komplett.
Wir können es verstehen,
wir können es fühlen.
Das habe ich bei meiner Mutter
eben eigentlich nie gehabt.
Ich dachte immer,
sie hätte mich zu wenig gern.
(Mann) Ja, richtig.
Ich hatte immer den Eindruck:
Da ist eine Distanz
zwischen Mutter und Tochter.
Hallo!
Hey!
- Hoi!
Im Schauspielhaus Zürich.
Regisseur Milo Rau hat Irma Frei
für sein Stück "Tell"
als Laiendarstellerin engagiert.
(Lautsprecher) Guten Abend,
meine Damen und Herren.
Es ist 19.03 Uhr.
Milo Rau kam dann und sagte:
"Irma, dich brauche ich genau,
du gehörst in dieses Stück."
Da sagte ich: "Was hat das
mit Wilhelm Tell zu tun?"
Da sagte er: "Jeder, der schon
einmal etwas Schlimmes erlebt hat,
hätte gerne einen Tell,
der ihn befreien würde."
"Du hättest sicher
auch gerne einen Tell gehabt,
der dich rausgeholt hätte,
aus dem Heim
und aus der Zwangsarbeit."
Da sagte ich:
"Ja, das stimmt, Milo."
"Und genau das
musst du den Leuten erzählen."
Tonprobe vor der Aufführung.
Die wenigsten wissen,
dass Bührle in den 60er-Jahren
auch Zwangsarbeiterinnen
in der Schweiz beschäftigt hat.
Ich war eine davon.
Okay.
(Alle) Brrrr.
Nach jeder Vorstellung ist es mir
ein Stück weit besser gegangen.
(Alle) Hei, hei, hey!
Ich bin froh
und ich bin erleichtert,
dass ich es endlich losgeworden bin.
Es kommt spät,
es kommt sehr spät.
Aber ich bin froh,
dass wir es überhaupt anpacken
und es noch Betroffene gibt,
die das erleben.
Als Kommissionspräsident
freue ich mich,
dass die Einstimmigkeit
gelungen ist.
Es ist durch. Einstimmig.
- Ehrlich?
Kann man hier nicht klatschen?
Gehört sich das nicht?
Nein.
Ich möchte klatschen.
Das ist gut, nicht?
Ich habe das dir zu verdanken.
Wirklich.
Das berührt dich, nicht wahr?
Ja, schon.
- Hei.
Wie geht es?
- Gut.
Gut. Aber ich habe Hunger.
Der Zürcher Gemeinderat beschliesst
die historische Aufarbeitung
und zahlt an jedes Zürcher Opfer
von Zwangsmassnahmen
einen Solidaritätsbeitrag
von 25'000 Fr.
Betroffene
aus anderen Kantonen und Gemeinden
müssen sich weiter gedulden.
Elfie Grendene
hat das Geld inzwischen erhalten.
Ich möchte sagen,
das ist unser Lohn.
Wir nehmen ihn auch heute noch gern.
Es ist eigentlich
wie ein Sparbüchlein.
Das hatten wir auf dem Sparbüchlein.
Jetzt können wir es brauchen.
* Melancholische Klavierklänge *
Es ist jetzt einfach mal fertig.
Ich will nichts mehr davon wissen.
Das ist noch
der schönste Moment von allen.
Das war eigentlich
noch eine schöne Schrift.
Es tut nicht einmal weh,
das Zeug zu verbrennen.
Abschied nehmen.
Ich hoffe, jenen,
die das geschrieben haben,
wird auch noch ein bisschen warm.
Jetzt fängt ein anderes Leben an.
Fertig.
Jetzt bin ich doch noch
alt und frech geworden.
Ja.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2023